[Música]
ah
entre los 2 y 6 años de edad
les doblaban los dedos de los pies hasta
casi reventar sus tendones
sin anestesia ni medicamento alguno para
mitigar su dolor
les hacían esto e imaginen la mirada
desconcertada de las niñas al ver que
eran sus propios padres madres tíos
quienes la sujetaba con fuerza para que
no escaparan de esta brutal tortura que
supuestamente la llevaría a la máxima
expresión de belleza
y les ayudaría a encontrar un buen
marido
les hacían esto
sin importarles los gritos y las
súplicas de sufrimiento de estas
indefensas niñas
te imaginas haber padecido esto cuando
eras niña te imaginas a tu hija a tu
hermana a tu sobrina en una habitación
experimentando esta brutal tortura a
manos de quienes se supone que deberían
de protegerlas
pero la tortura a nuestra mente y
nuestro cuerpo no es cosa del pasado
a pesar de la abolición de la esclavitud
de la libertad de pensamiento que existe
hoy en día y de cada uno de los logros
de los grupos de derechos humanos que
nos permiten ser vistos más como un ser
humano integral y menos como una cosa
la tortura a nuestras mentes y nuestros
cuerpos
en algunos países de la misma forma
brutal y abierta y en otros de una
manera más sutil y simbólica sin embargo
es tortura en toda la extensión de la
palabra
una de las torturas que me impresiona
que siga vigente en estos días son los
concursos de belleza para niñas
patrocinados por grandes televisoras
financiados por marcas internacionales y
con una numerosa audiencia estos por
donde los veas son una brutal violación
a los derechos de la niñez ni siquiera
unicef u otros grupos internacionales
ponen alto a estos concursos donde las
niñas son hipersexualizadas mostradas
como mercancía para ser juzgadas por su
cuerpo
a ellas se les roba el tesoro más
importante que puede tener un ser humano
su inocencia
se les aplica botox pelucas se les
aparta de su sistema escolar por seguir
el ritmo de los concursos de belleza y
todo esto nuevamente con el mismo
objetivo de cumplir con un estándar de
belleza y de ser juzgadas
sin embargo ellas no son las únicas
existen otro tipo de violaciones como el
'blog' esta es una práctica que se hace
actualmente en áfrica donde a las niñas
a partir de los 5 años de edad son
enviadas a granjas de engorde y
obligadas a comer grandes cantidades de
comida y si vomitan porque sus estómagos
no resisten más son obligadas a comerse
su propio vómito son torturadas con
pinzas que lastiman sus manos y sus pies
como como castigo por no comer las
enormes cantidades indicadas
desde temprana edad les causan un
sinnúmero de enfermedades todo
nuevamente con el mismo objetivo de
alcanzar un estándar de belleza y ser
colocadas en grandes familias donde
podrán tener la protección de un hombre
y aunque áfrica puede sonar muy lejana
para nuestra realidad estoy segura que
tú así como yo alguna vez de alguna
manera también te has torturado con
estas antiguas ideas en las que se
justifican estas terribles prácticas y
lo sé porque las estadísticas son
enormes y tristes para los
investigadores el 90% de las mujeres
entrevistadas dijo que se sentían y
conformes con al menos una parte de su
cuerpo el 67 por ciento de las mujeres
entrevistadas respondieron que evitan
acciones tales como dar su opinión ir a
la escuela o ir al doctor porque se
avergüenzan de su cuerpo en otra
entrevista 54
las distintas mujeres de bachillerato
entrevistadas dijeron que preferían ser
golpeadas por un camión antes que subir
de peso en un estudio que se hizo el
méxico con más de 10.000 estudiantes
entre los 6 y los 16 años se concluyó
que el 63% para ellos una niña o una
niña con sobrepeso
eran igual a los sinónimos de fealdad
[ __ ] como peyorativo y discriminatorio
y tonto en ese mismo estudio se
descubrió que muchos niños preferían
tener una discapacidad temporal antes de
subir de peso y es que hemos fallado en
enseñarle a nuestros niños hay que
cuidar su cuerpo porque lo aman y no por
miedo a ser avergonzado
otra cosa que tienen en común estas
torturas antiguas y contemporáneas es
que en la mayoría de los casos son y han
sido dirigidos a las mujeres y el
problema es que muchas formas cultas
activistas o revolucionarias que podamos
ser muchas veces no podemos identificar
esta voz destructiva en nuestra cabeza y
lo proyectamos en el espejo con nuestras
inseguridades y sobre todo creyendo que
no seremos capaces de alcanzar nuestras
metas y es que para la persona que no
encaja en el estándar ha sido condenado
a la burla ya la invisibilización
quiero compartirles
una poderosa historia que resume todo lo
que quiero transmitirles en esta charla
es acerca de natalia una niña de 3 años
que estaba en su guardería cuando
desgraciadamente ésta se incendió
ni ella ni su familia ham
se habrían imaginado que pasarían por
este terrible accidente y el posterior
sufrimiento que significaría sobrevivir
al incendio
ella es una de mis pacientes y fue
víctima de la tragedia infantil más
grande de la historia de mexico el
incendio de la guardería abc
por cuestiones de intransigencia en las
instalaciones e infraestructura del
lugar ella junto con sus compañeritos
quedó atrapada en la guardería sin poder
salir mientras ésta se incendiaba por
dentro
sin duda es un tema muy delicado
muy doloroso
y fue un terrible accidente que se pudo
haber prevenido en el que murieron 49
niños y niñas
y muchos otros quedaron con secuelas y
con quemaduras de por vida en aquel
entonces
natalia tenía tres años y es una de las
sobrevivientes tuvo quemaduras graves y
profundas en diferentes partes de su
cuerpo y estuvo a punto de perder la
vida
una de las zonas más afectadas fue su
pierna para poder salvarla los médicos
le hicieron injertos y para poder
irrigar de sangre el tejido injertado
tuvieron que coser su pie izquierdo
[Música]
estuvo en esta posición sin poderse
mover durante cuatro meses imagina lo
que esto significa para una niña de tres
años y su familia
hoy natalia y su madre han querido que
por primera vez se cuente su historia
porque ellas tienen un mensaje de fuerza
y esperanza que quieren compartir con
nosotros al día de hoy natalia tiene 12
años y ha pasado por 25 cirugías en tan
solo 9 años y continúa en largos
procesos de recuperación y aprendió a
muy temprana edad que de un momento a
otro nuestro cuerpo puede cambiar y como
consecuencia nuestra vida entera
la madre de natalee al darse cuenta de
este cambio radical en su vida y en la
vida de su hija se replanteó el
significado de la vida y del cuerpo
enseñó a su hija que es en el ser donde
radica su valor como mujer y como ser
humano y de esta manera la apretaron
para enfrentar de una mejor manera un
mundo que juzga a una persona por su
apariencia
se podrán imaginar que para ellas el
camino no ha sido fácil porque además de
luchar incansablemente por salvar la
vida de natalia y sintiéndose agotadas
día a día por todo lo que se tiene que
hacer para lograrlo además tiene que
salir y luchar contra un mundo que da
valor a una persona por como luce vaya
ayuda que le estamos dando a ella ya
todos los niños y las niñas del mundo
para sentirse suficientes a pesar de que
han luchado por la vida contra la
corrupción contra los estigmas sociales
donde han tenido todo en contra ellas se
han centrado en lo importante que es
cultivar la belleza del alma ante la
adversidad
hoy natalia es un adolescente alegre y
funcional campeona en varios deportes y
aunque sigue siendo sometida a dolorosas
cirugías y tendrá que hacerlo durante
algunos años más la visión que tiene
sobre la vida y sobre su cuerpo va más
allá de la apariencia natalia nos
recuerda la importancia del desarrollo
del sentido de la vida y lo maravilloso
que puede ser nuestro cuerpo cuando se
trata de sobrevivir y salir adelante
algo
por lo cual
no debemos torturarle y debemos de estar
agradecidos
pero sobre todo nos enseña a ganar la
verdadera batalla que es trascender a la
presión cultural y sobrevivir con el
alma intacta
a las dificultades de la vida valorar y
amar nuestro cuerpo a pesar de sus
cicatrices pues debemos entender que son
marcas de guerra ganada
el mensaje que nos une a todas en cierto
punto desde las niñas de flor de loto le
blow natalia a ti ya mí es que muchas de
nosotras
muchas veces libramos duras batallas en
el desarrollo de nuestra vida ya sea
porque tengamos una historia marcada por
un accidente o como yo que fui víctima
de violencia en casa pobreza
y librar estas batallas nos deja heridas
y agotadas y salimos a un mundo que nos
revictimiza haciéndonos sentir que
aunque hayamos ganado esa batalla de
vida aunque hayamos sobrevivido a esa
situación
no lucimos y no somos lo suficientemente
valiosas como para evitar el mundo y
vivirlo de manera cómoda y nuestra
propia piel de cierta manera está
continua descalificación nos obliga a
seguir luchando por sentirnos seguras
suficientes y dignas de reconocimiento
esto además de ser injusto es agotador
y
y esto es algo que tenemos que cambiar
la vida
va más allá de la apariencia y pareciera
que es algo del cuerpo y la apariencia
pero es un ataque directo a nuestra
mente ya nuestra alma donde el mundo
entero pierde porque la búsqueda del
estándar inalcanzable e insostenible nos
distrae y nos hace menos productivas en
todos los aspectos después algo que
tenemos que cambiar por eso aquí y ahora
los invito a que hagamos una revolución
donde le mandemos este mensaje a las
niñas y niños resiste la presión
cultural y mediática rebélate a la idea
de que alguien tenía que decirte cómo
debes de lucir o lo que tienes que hacer
si deseas tener éxito
no te escondas
no te avergüences de tu cuerpo no te
distraigas tratando de cambiar tu cuerpo
para después mostrar tus talentos la
vida es muy
y tus dones son muy grandes la vida es
ahora y no hay tiempo de esconderse por
eso alcanza tus sueños cobras de vida
junto con este cuerpo para amar besar
bailar cantar dar vida besar oler idear
resolver
el cuerpo no es un objeto que se luce es
una herramienta que se usa para
maximizar nuestra experiencia no
sabremos cuánto tiempo viviremos y
solamente tendremos una oportunidad así
que es por tus sueños no te detengas
toma tu cuerpo usa tu cerebro y haz de
esta oportunidad de vivir la experiencia
humana más extraordinaria que pudiste
haber creado
soy olga gonzález psicóloga clínica ya
lo largo de 16 años he tenido el honor
de acompañar a cientos de pacientes
a trascender a situaciones
si lees y dolorosas en sus vidas y han
sido cada una de estas experiencias las
que me han enseñado que hay que abrazar
y celebrar la vida en todas sus formas
porque porque la vida no debería de ser
un viaje hacia la tumba con la única
intención de llegar con un cuerpo bonito
y bien conservado sino más bien
deberíamos de llegar sonriendo
derrapando del lado envueltos en una
nube de polvo completamente desgastadas
y proclamar en voz alta un maravilloso
vaya viajecito
[Aplausos]